sur ces news en octobre 2020 il y avait
une émission qui était spécialement
consacrée aux mineurs étrangers isolés
vous avez déclaré il y as entre 40000 et
50000 mineurs isolés qui arrivent par an
en france
il coûte à l'aide sociale cinquante
mille euros par an
ça nous fait à peu près deux milliards
minimum est ce que vous vous a confirmé
ses propos c'est des chiffres que j'ai
vu dans un article et que donc j'ai
repris parce qu'ils étaient fiables ils
ne sont pas fiables et tout est faux une
fin avril comme d'habitude avec vous bah
oui mais c'est vous qui avez raison vous
avez la perrita révélé c'est connu
d'autres journalistes travaillent
pas de solution il te faire parce que
c'est bon le professeur qui dit qui
travaillent qui ne travaillent pas non
je constate simplement oui bien sortir
vous avez décidé d'être candidat à la
présence de république il faut quand
même que vous acceptiez d'être jugé par
des gens par le peuple france j'ai
toujours aimé juge français dont je fais
partie et également par les journalistes
que vous vous posiez cadieux voulons
savoir si un candidat de qualité ça
quand même vous l'acceptez ça s'appelle
la démocratie met donc sur l'immigration
sur la pologne est vrai je vous le donne
et je donne et non juste faut quand même
savoir les mineurs isolés au camp nous
explique aux gens ce coup c'est ce soir
ce sont des mineurs qui a risqué soin de
l'étranger et qu'ils n'ont avec eux qui
n'ont pas de référent adulte qui
s'occupe de voix là et il se trouve que
ça gêne beaucoup les zemmour parce qu'il
peut la loi oblige l'état français à
s'occuper de leur donner une aide qui
s'appelle l'az l'aide sociale à
l'enfance il dit ça coûte beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent à la france oui c'est
terrible moyenne à 50 milles qui
arrivent chaque année donc c'est
incroyable on essaie l'invasion dont
nous parle eric zemmour tout en en
réalité il y à chaque année entre 10000
et les derniers chiffres et 17000 à peu
près qui arrivent chaque année le
chiffre que vous avez donnée de 40
milles il est bien dans un rapport mais
que vous avez mal lu comme vous lisez
mal tous les rapports que vous lisez
c'est un rapport physique qui parle de
40 milles c'est la globalité de tous les
mineurs étrangers isolés qui sont sur le
territoire français le coup en fin de
ces mineurs étrangers isolés il n'est
pas du tout de 50000 euros par enfant
aujourd'hui elle est parfois des
systèmes dans certains départements ça
ne coûte que 8000 euros et insu donc
vous voyez vos chiffres à vous c'est 5
fois la résistance est à peu près avec
pas du tout c'est comme l'est celle de
50000 euros en 1950 1000 euros et celui
d'un président de conseil général je me
souviens très bien du papier mat alors
et brûler vous avez le don de prendre
des chiffres que j'ai cités il ya un an
il ya deux ans il ya dix ans et
évidemment je ne peux rien vérifier
parce que moi je n'ai pas les je n'ai
rien sous la main
de 31 ans faux ce que vous venez d'eric
zemmour car peut-être le coup à chaque
étape et comment donc vous me fait le
coup à chaque fois la dernière
phase a concerné des chiffres tirés exe
moore que vous l avez senti des années
aventure vous aviez écrit j'aimerais
maintenant les gens et qu'on se
concentre la 3000e d'immigration rtl des
années regagne ensuite mis dans un livre
là en l'occurrence il s'agit de six vous
allez donner lors d'une émission que
vous aviez préparé qui était
spécialement consacrée au sujet et tous
vos chiffres sont faux t elle son bien
et comme les chiffres des étrangers qui
avaient chaque année en france que vous
avez rappelé à villebrumier ils sont
également car alors là on va en parler
alors alors les a alors ces chiffres
sont absolument vraies vous avez parlé
de deux millions me semble-t-il de
mémoire ces deux nouveaux étrangers en
cinq ans à venir pendant le quinquennat
et bien sûr je vous avais dit que c'est
l'équivalent de la ville de paris bien
sûr maîtriser entièrement
alors je vais redonner une scène on le
voit alors j'ai un nom à laisser leur
est pas les seuls
oui laisser leurs avis maintenant la
mode non mais parce que sinon vous
faites un humain mais on va on parle de
ce chiffre des 2 millions alors est ce
bien vrai ce qui laissait tracy arrêtons
nous là dessus vous avez 275000 d'entrée
légal de titre de séjour données en 2019
vous avez cent quarante mille cent
quarante mille droit d'asile là dessus
vous avez trente mille à 35000 qui sont
acceptés vous savez tout le reste qui
sont déboutés qui devrait rentrer chez
eux or ils ne rendent quasiment pas chez
eux il ya à peu près seulement 10 à 15%
de ses donc 540 milles - trente-six
mille c'est à peu près cent dix mille
qui qui repartent donc il reste à peu
près entre 75 milles et 90000 qui
restent ici donc vous rajoutez les 275
milles aux 90 milles ça vous fait
combien entre 350 et 400 et vous faites
ça sur cinq ans ça vous fait 2000 alors
voce sont faux j'invite tous les
spectateurs à se rendre sur le site le
site de l'insee où vous pourrez lire les
chiffres année paranatation bauchi vous
est pris de l'insee bon c'est à peu près
ça aux chiffres le sol de microgaming
j'ai maudit dominion vous dit combien il
y en a quand même commis sept cent
cinquante mille à peu près oui monsieur
monsieur car on fait un truc habituels
n'ont pas tendance à couper la parole
mais bien sûr monsieur caron alors je
termine le cso a trouvé 750 me ludot
millions dans les chais lettonie c'est
parce que il y avait évidemment des gens
qui arrivent il ya aucun marseillais
dont j'ai joué en tunisie il ya un an
car il ya des gens qui repart oui bien
sûr qu'ils repartent chaque année et là
c'est vrai ça c'est oui ça monsieur car
bientôt il y en a aussi il y en a aussi
qui décèdent donc eh oui monsieur et
aaron feltham actuelle non c'est à dire
qu'ils souffraient que je vous ai donné
il souffrait de l'insee que jeudi
pendant une heure encore hier au
téléphone mais après chacun fait et vous
le premier il ya un surmoi le prône
alors seulement vous et moi on vous fait
un truc habituel que vous parlez de
solde migratoire il a bien dit seuls
nice et sabam et le sol ni en louise et
la différence en lessard eux les
étrangers qui arrivent et
les gens qui partent ou est pas les
étrangers monsieur caron là dedans il ya
des français monsieur caron qui passe et
le solde migratoire par les panneaux
sans solde migratoire joue la différence
non moi je les jeunes qui arrivent et le
chant qui le
papa de cela mais bien sûr que non c'est
pas ça mais aymeric caron je voudrais
maintenant parce que nous reste que très
peu de temps sur un sujet qui mériterait
au moins deux heures je vous aimerai n'y
reviendrai ça nous a vraiment bien je
vous le voudrez vous montrer une
photographie
c'est quoi
oui on se rappelle tous de cette photo
et lan cé
configuration géographique qui a fait le
tour du monde à ilan trois ans échoué
sur une plage de turquie non en 2015
son frère qui est mort avec lui dans le
naufrage sa mère également c'est une
famille qui fuyait la syrie qui fut l
état islamique
qu'est-ce que vous inspire cette photo
écoutez comme tout drame d'un enfant qui
meurt c'est triste c'est désolant c'est
désespérant
c'est malheureusement
la vie la mort
c'est très triste un enfant qui meurt ça
attriste et ça désespère tout le monde
maintenant on ne fait pas on ne bâtit
pas une politique sur
une émotion ont bâti une politique quand
on est le président de la france sur
l'intérêt des français et l'intérêt des
français c'est de ne plus accueillir
aucun ni midway parce que l'immigration
n'est plus une chance pour la france
depuis longtemps c'est une malchance
pour la france depuis des années et donc
moi je veut arrêter toute immigration
c'est à dire que les 275 mille entrées
légales seront réduites si je pierre si
je prend le pouvoir à presque rien car
nous supprimerons le droit au
regroupement familial nous supprimerons
le la planification familiale nous
réduirons à presque rien le droit
d'asile et les dé ceux qui déposeront
leur dé leur demande de droit d'asile le
feront dans les consulats à l'étranger
et nous expulserons les clandestins et
nous expulserons en plus les délinquants
étrangers et nous ferons la déchéance de
nationalité pour les doubles
nationalités délinquants et en plus
monsieur 40 je vais pousser
en plus votre état au bord de
l'apoplexie je renverrai aussi les
chômeurs de plus de six mois les
chômeurs étrangers je sais tout ça voilà
monsieur k est vrai qu est ce que vous
pouvez répondre a ajouté trois villes
qui reste une minute trente qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ça ben d'abord que
je suis constant de constater qu'au
moins eric zemmour et prouve ce soir un
petit peu de tristesse en voyant cette
photo il a évolué puisque peut pas on
peut pas ne pas éprouver de tristesse
drame aussi puisqu'en janvier 2020
lorsqu'on lui demandait ce qu'il pensait
des enfants qui mouraient en
méditerranée eric zemmour répondait je
n'en ai cure je m'en fout quoi pour
défendre mes enfants je préfère que
l'autre meurt
on ne leur a rien demandé ce sont pour
moi des envahisseurs donc voilà je suis
content de voir que vous avez au moins
aujourd'hui éprouvée un petit peu de
tristesse et pour terminer monsieur
terminé brillamment
devant fessionnels de la compassion le
code c'est du professionnalisme chez
vous vous exploitez la compassion moi
pas c'est la différence on aimerait
terminer je me demande si un homme qui
tient ce genre de propos peut vraiment
être candidat à la présidence d'un pays
démocratique comme la france je suis pas
sûr je me surtout si un homme il tient
des propos vous êtes tenir trop de
compassion du sentimentalisme d'oran la
photo cette intention d'exercer l'option
de la compassion par des professionnels
comme moi je me demande si pour un noir
mais l'est de la france soit envahi moi
je me demande si m
qui fait preuve de tant d'indifférence
finalement à la mort d'un enfant
appartient encore à l'humanité